madame Sophie met pour le groupe
démocrate
[Applaudissements]
ma question s'adresse à Madame Rima
Abdul Malek ministre de la Culture en
France il était un domaine qui pèse 19
milliards d'euros de chiffre d'affaires
il repose sur seulement 150000
professionnels et 60 000 entreprises qui
pour la grande majorité sont
individuelles j'évoque ici les 281
métiers d'art qui font la fierté de
notre pays dans le monde entier
aujourd'hui vous avez annoncé le
déploiement d'une stratégie nationale en
faveur des métiers d'art inédits pour un
secteur puissant et que tous les
Français connaissent grâce à notre
patrimoine si varié les savoir-faire
français en matière d'artisanat de l'art
à la fois traditionnel et innovant sont
d'une richesse infinie comme en
témoignent les compétences
exceptionnelles mobilisées des
charpentes jusqu'au dorures de la
cathédrale Notre-Dame de Paris
restaurateur verrier tailleur de pierre
tourne tourneur sur bois les défis sont
grands à commencer par celui du
recrutement les formations pour ces
métiers d'exception ne font pas ne sont
pas liés il est crucial de faire
connaître nos ateliers d'encourager la
création française de valoriser ces
métiers auprès des jeunes et de donner
une réponse à cette orientation une
partie de ces défis doit être relevée
par l'outil puissant de démocratisation
culturelle qui est le Pass Culture en
quoi consiste les nouvelles activités
d'initiation que vous proposerez à notre
jeunesse enfin rappelons que les métiers
d'art s'inscrivent contre la production
de masse et jetables le recyclage de
plastique est courant ainsi que la
réutilisation de chutes de tissu ou même
de matière organique c'est notre rôle
que d'encourager les pratiques durables
cela passe par le développement de
réseaux de proximité par une logique
d'économie circulaire et de production
locale comment mettre en place des
mesures efficaces qui se déclineront sur
tous nos territoires et notamment dans
la ruralité je vous remercie merci
beaucoup